en este vídeo vamos a instalar el
interruptor que pueden ver en la parte
de abajo en el centro de la pantalla que
es nuestro interruptor de encendido para
nuestra bici lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es tomar el interruptor y pasarlo
por el agujero que hicimos para él en un
vídeo anterior el agujero es apenas lo
suficientemente grande como para que
quepa el interruptor así que nos llevará
un poco de tiempo para colocarlo al
igual que un poco de habilidad para
hacerlo después pondremos la tuerca en
el interruptor para mantenerlo en su
lugar usamos nuestro destornillador para
ayudarnos a colocarla y la atornilla más
a mano lo que va a requerir cuidado y
paciencia para poder alinearla con el
eje del interruptor y después le damos
vueltas para asegurarla nos lleva algo
de tiempo hacerlo porque el lugar es
pequeño debido a los componentes que ya
tenemos instalados y por estar cerca de
la orilla pero bueno
estamos logrando al final usamos
nuestras pinzas de nariz de punta para
terminar de asegurar la tuerca ahora
vamos a soldar los cables a nuestro
interruptor tenemos el cable positivo
que sale de la batería lo vamos a cortar
a la longitud correcta y vamos a pelar
su extremo después lo vamos a doblar
dándole forma de uno lo que nos ayudará
a que el cable rodee al contacto del
interruptor queremos darle una forma de
un bien hecha para que nos ayude a que
el cable se enganche bien al contacto y
ya que se enganchó usamos nuestras
pinzas de nariz de aguja para apretar un
poco mejor esto en su lugar
una vez que el cable se encuentra
firmemente en su lugar vamos a soldar el
cable en el poste del interruptor lo que
hace el interruptor es básicamente
detener el flujo de electricidad al
desconectar los cables
ya soldamos este cable y también
soldamos el otro cable en el otro lado
este otro cable irá directamente a
nuestro controlador del motor y es de
aquí de donde vendrá la corriente la
energía de las baterías irá al
controlador del motor y el interruptor
nos permitirá terminar este flujo y
apagará nuestro robot
pasamos nuestros cables de energía por
debajo y a través de los agujeros por
encima del controlador del motor de
manera que ahora pelamos el extremo del
cable
este es nuestro cable de energía de 12
volts y va a ir al pin en nuestro bloque
terminal en el extremo derecho de este
bloque en el centro ya habíamos aflojado
los tornillos y ahora insertamos el
cable en el pin y después apretamos el
tornillo para mantenerlo en su lugar y
que no se salga
este es el cable que viene directamente
de nuestro interruptor aquí apretamos el
tornillo de nuestro bloque terminal y
ahora tenemos nuestro cable negativo que
viene directamente de la batería y lo
vamos a colocar en el pin que se
encuentra a la extrema izquierda en este
mismo bloque terminal que es nuestro
cable de tierra pelamos el extremo de
este cable lo insertamos por debajo del
tornillo a la izquierda del bloque ahora
tomamos nuestro cable de calibre 22 y lo
vamos a conectar a tierra lo que nos
permitirá conectar otros dispositivos a
la tierra de la tarjeta usando nuestro
controlador de motor como nuestra caja
de unión
así que colocamos este nuevo cable en la
misma terminal de la izquierda del
bloque en donde pusimos nuestro cable de
calibre 18 que viene de nuestras
baterías
no hay mucho espacio pero vamos a seguir
reacomodando los cables hasta que quepan
bien los dos las pinzas no son de mucha
ayuda para de empujar los cables hacia
adentro finalmente tomamos el
destornillador y apretamos el tornillo
de la terminal para asegurar en su lugar
ambos cables ahora tomamos otro cable de
calibre 22 lo pelamos y lo colocamos en
el pin de en medio de este bloque
terminal y nos va a proporcionar 5volts
de salida que usaremos para encender
nuestra cámara digital nuestro arduino y
otros componentes en nuestra tarjeta lo
que haremos en los siguientes vídeos